- [Melissa Proctor:]
The energy of Atlanta
is incredibly interesting,
and I think it's different
than anywhere in the nation.
The idea of mixing
Southern hospitality
with kind of an old-school
Southern flair
with a lot of new energy,
pop culture.
- [John Collins:] The colleges,
the amount of Black businesses
that are here,
Atlanta strives
for Black excellence.
- There's a great energy
about the city.
I can identify with the legacy
and the history of civil rights.
- This was the backyard
of some of the greatest
civil rights leaders
of all times.
- The SCLC being founded
in Atlanta,
the history of Black leadership.
- [Wilkins:]
Maynard Jackson and Andrew Young
and Dr. King,
all of them started here,
really put Atlanta
on the world map.
- When Nike came on board
with the NBA
and created
the City Edition platform—
- It was kind of
a revolutionary idea
to, like, have a jersey
that ties to the city
and is expressive
and allows for teams to tell
community stories
in impactful ways.
- My very first year
was trying to distinguish
what the City Edition
would be for this season.
So, it's been about
a three-year-long process.
The idea of partnering
with the King estate
was an early idea that I had.
- When the Hawks approached us
about the MLK City Edition
uniform concept,
we were very intrigued.
Whenever we have an opportunity,
we try to move Dr. King
from the history books
and into the lives
of younger generations.
- And so sitting down with
the Nike team, they embraced it.
- We actually had a team member
who traveled out to Atlanta
to visit with the team
and got a lot of pictures
and inspiration.
- [Proctor:] Went to
Ebenezer Baptist Church
and went to the King Center.
- When he brought all that back,
it was just really inspiring.
- [Proctor:] In partnership
with the King estate
in developing this entire idea,
they were so excited.
- There was no hesitation at all
on linking Dr. King's
legacy to sports.
We realize the power of sports
and the medium that it is,
so we thought
it made perfect sense
to partner
with the Hawks on this.
- Honoring Dr. King
is a natural connection for us.
- We knew that, like,
this is more than just a jersey.
It means so much more to us.
♪♪♪
- [Tidwell:] Each element
of the design of the uniform has
a specific meaning and intent,
so it was well thought out
in that way.
- There were a number of
elements to the uniform
that really speaks to Dr. King.
Obviously, the black and gold
as a nod to his fraternity,
Alpha Phi Alpha.
- The side panel on the shorts,
we had intended that arch
to kinda hearken back
to church window panes.
- [Proctor:] The stars represent
the student freedom fighters
that were a part
of the movement.
- [Coleman:] The wordmark,
obviously reading “MLK,”
that's never been done before,
a person's initials being donned
on the jersey.
- [Proctor:] All of it comes
together to really represent
what this uniform
means to the city of Atlanta.
- I had a chance
to get a sneak peek at ‘em.
- It’s just, it’s pure fire.
- I'm getting texts and calls
that people were gonna
go get it.
- [Tidwell:]
The NBA definitely seems to be
the league that's leading
the encouragement
of athlete activism.
- Continue to uplift
all the other athletes,
to let them know
that they can say
and do what's right.
- We won't be silent.
Enough is enough.
- To wear those three letters
across our chest, it's
gotta mean something to you.
- I gotta play just
a little bit harder
when I have that jersey on.
- This is not just a new
uniform. It is a commitment.
- We can continue to have
those conversations
about what Dr. King's legacy
truly means
and what we can do
to play our part
in addressing
the efforts moving forward.
- I try to carry out his legacy
and his messages.
I look at everybody
as an individual.
It's not the color of your skin.
It's the content
of your character.
- It's so important
to keep educating ourselves
about the importance
of equality.
That message will never get old.
- I don't know if there’s
another way
that you can represent
the city of Atlanta better
than representing through
Dr. Martin Luther King.
- We want this uniform
to really be something
historic that people hold on to
and really take pride in
for years to come.
But we wanna make sure that
we continue this conversation
and that people
don't just talk about it,
they do the work.
And earning these letters for us
means exactly that.
♪♪♪